questa è questo che cos'è parlino la
bongiorno pronti 5 4 3 2 1 via
che cosa c'è dentro un uovo berlino thai
attento ma non mi sembra di vedere
niente come niente non c'è niente
all'interno oppure se leggiamo giado
berlino e vino o non c'è niente per
davvero
10 minuti ma com'è possibile che le
tracce venivano qua se non segnerete
dentro forse si è nascosto al centro per
mangiare tutto o è scappato all'ultimo
momento e cosa è scappato qualche mica
una porta o fai allora come faremo a
scoprire che cosa è entrato in casa e
non lo so mi è venuta un'idea
guardala su nostra camera di sicurezza
stiamo guardare le camere di sicurezza
che registrano sempre così siamo vedere
chi è entrato in casa che cos'è che
animale
ok andiamo subito a vederle sono troppo
curiosa di scoprire che cos'è berlino
chi è stato secondo te entrare in casa
tu l'hai visto
ok ragazzi se vuoi per vedere le
registrazioni delle camere di sicurezza
mettetevi comodi e ricordatevi di
lasciare un bel mi piace su questo video
pronti via
ok ecco la registrazione del salotto
berlino dal tuo sito
entrato berlino in salotto ecco che
cos'è la vuoi rumore che abbiamo sentito
allora quindi forse è stato merlino o
mangiare con le cose a buttare giù i
pupazzi non è entrato nessuno
continuiamo a vedere fino a un pagarsi
copriamo qualcos'altro
è qui che si guarda intorno questa è
questo che cos'è un coniglio un gatto un
furetto allora mi sono traversato il
faro forse un porcellino d'india anche
se alle orecchie un po crearmi orecchie
così lunga infatti sembra più delle
orecchie da asino attaccato a un
porcellino d'india
se andiamo a guardare vediamo se si vede
mediche ma la cucina e sembra che rimane
strano come muove la testa e le camere
in camera da letto ha buttato via tutti
i peluche
quindi è stato questo strano animale
come lui evitare mi dispiace di averti
incolpato di tutte quelle cose l'avevo
detto che non sono stato io a mangiarmi
tutte quelle cose ma chi animale è un
topo un gatto un furetto che cos'è non
ruba cibo dai ragazzi scrivete poi
secondo qualche animale perché vitale
ormai non ragiona più visto che ha visto
qualcuno per chi ruba chi è così e
infatti mi è venuta un'idea se noi
guardiamo le camere di sicurezza in
diretta si quindi non la registrazione
sì forse riusciamo a capire dov'è
l'animaletto se si nasconde ancora in
casa nostra e in che stanza è per andare
a prenderlo e per mestre da qualsiasi
parte magari proprio con la in questa
stanza che ci osserva ok controlliamo le
carré diretta ce li diamo che istanza
guardiamo prima ovviamente da cucina
va bene ecco qua la cucina sembra tutto
tranquillo non c'è niente la camera da
letto ok ok proviamo adesso il corridoio
sembra tutto normale
per fortuna quindi vuol dire che se n'è
andato oppure si nasconde in un punto in
cui le camere di sicurezza non prendono
cv sia nascosta guida eccolo da sé
qualcosa che si muove cosa sotto il
tavolo
lui sembra proprio lui si è ora nello
studio al piano di sopra che facciamo
rosso andiamo subito a prenderlo
aspettiamo e vediamo dove va vediamo
prima doveva magari esce fuori
direttamente ok si sta muovendo su
berlino lo meno non giorno c'è nel
corridoio uno scrittoio berlino lo sta
inseguendo
o no ricerca per volta gioca mangiando
cambiamo visuale
eccolo sta arrivando giù dalle scale che
succede con berlino sta cercando di
difendere ci guardiamo la scala che è
scale a farlo qui allora visto è passato
dallo studio al corridoio all'altro
corridoio alle scale quindi sta per
arrivare qui lo più da quella porta sta
scendendo lungo dietro
c'è nessuno
berlino hai visto per caso quello di
maletto del vino nel messo da qualche
parte ma vuoi vedere anche tu le camere
di sicurezza del vino si è accomodato
vuole vedere quindi le camere di
sicurezza nel libro hai visto meglio di
tutti ho visto che lei era in corso dai
merlino dimmi dove è andato così
possiamo andare a prenderlo
lì non vuole veder meno il nome di
simone disse dove è andato l'animaletto
eppure strano e si è saputa alle scale
assieme a lui ma non c'è più forse è
meglio mettersi a cercarlo e sceso qui
non possiamo lasciare qui a vagare da
solo dobbiamo metterci a cercarlo
magari dividiamoci io controllo il
salotto e tu cosa vuoi controllare
ovviamente io vado a controllare così
anzi è proprio che giusto ok ai freni
non è che abbia mangiato
mangiare io no
giardino mi aiuti a settare la limonetto
ovvero gli aiuti comunque mi è venuta
un'altra idea se non riesco a trovarlo
provato a tirarlo con un po di cibo
proprio come faccio con vita le fece
berlino hai trovato qualcosa
berlino ha trovato qualcosa fammi vedere
che cos'è di massa
berlino non si mangia ma che cosa vuol
dire questo bigliettino e molto strano e
scritto in inglese c'è scritto ricordati
delle regole evita le luci molto forti
non dargli da mangiare dopo mezzanotte
non bagnarlo mai e poi sopra c'è scritta
una parola strana ghismo fra il nome
dell'animaletto o forse un qualcosa in
un'altra lingua
bravissimo merlino che hai trovato
questo indizio per il mio fedele
aiutante bravissimo ora circa il resto
cerca cerca certa il camerino gioca
[Musica]
mi sembra di vedere qualcosa d'altro che
di berlino bravo l'hai trovato anche tu
bravo morlino che trovato tutti gli
indizi e non lo strano chiare però ok ok
bravissimo berlino meno da reti per
favore no ma mi ha fatto cadere dentro
il cassetto aspetta aprire il cassetto
a che prezzo
strano in questo biglietto praticamente
si sono scritte quasi le stesse cose
tranne che c'è un'immagine con scritto
fragile forse questo animaletto è stato
trasportato in una scatola è stato
spedito da qualche parte attenzione
ricordati delle regole niente luce forte
non dargli da mangiare dopo mezzanotte e
non bagnarli per nessun motivo
ma perché non ripetuto queste regole
vabbè vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro in
giro
berlino ha trovato qualcosa che cosa hai
trovato un arrivo
no ma quello è l'indizio di prima lo
stai facendo bene
marino ha gran occhiato l'indizio di
prima
no no no non so più dove cercare questo
mostriciattolo con gli indizi non
volevano dire niente
[Musica]
che cos'è questo suono
proviene da dietro al divano
[Musica]
[Applauso]